He's tall, I'm short get over it. *laughs*
'Sup guys? I'm King of Random.
I'm Collins Key
And today we're making RAINBOW instant ice
So a lot of people have seen my video on
making instant ice, I did it about 4 years ago on my channel.
It blew up on my channel, a lot of people have done it since.
But I've never seen anybody try using food coloring to change the color of the water itself.
So that's what we've got here today, we've got five different colors of the rainbow.
The challenge is, can we make colored water, get it to the right temperature, and freeze it all at once?
That is the question, what do you think?
Yeah, I think we can.
I'm here with The King Of Random, bro. Like if anyone can do it, this guy can right here, so
I couldn't do it but I'm pretty confident.
The first time I saw the instant ice it reminded me of
real magic, and for me, like I'm a magician I do magic
and stuff and it blew my mind I thought at first
it was a trick, I'm like, "How does this work?", and then
when I saw your video, I'm like, "Oh, I want to do this!".
Well, I did it and I could not get it to work, it was literally
just water or as an icicle every single time.
So today, I think we're actually gonna be able to like,
figure out this sorcery and be able to do it.
one thing i never told to you guys that this trick was inspired
inspired when I was working in the airlines.
There was an airport we used to park at and one of
the pilots would put water bottles on the
dashboard of the cockpit and leave them overnight and
when we'd come back in the morning, he'd flick them,
and the whole water bottle would freeze, and that
began the journey into figuring out how we can make
this happen at home.
Now you know. *GYAH* *laughs*
So here's the plan guys.
We just went down to the grocery store, we picked up
a couple of water bottles,
now these are just regular water bottles
you get right off the shelf.
They haven't been opened yet but we
did take the labels off.
Not sure if that takes the magic out but
we wanted you to see the full effect.
Now we also went to the store and picked up a
variety of food colorings here,
we're going to be filling the waters with to create create the rainbow effect.
So here's the thinking guys, originally we thought it was because
the water was so pure that it would crystalize.
But, after I made this trick with soda,
inspired by a vending machine in Hong Kong,
I thought maybe we should try adding food coloring
to to see if that would have any effect.
So here's the premise of our experiment today.
We're gonna take one of these beautiful water bottles, from the store,
unopened, we're gonna crack the caps, add 4 drops of food coloring to each one
of these bottles, set them in the freezer, for anywhere from 3 to 4 hours, because apparently,
that's how long your freezer takes.
My freezers weak man, his freezer takes 90 minutes, mine takes
like 4 hours, fam.
Then we're gonna bring them out, pour them in a tray of crushed ice, and see if we can achieve the effect
comparable to an ice rainbow, forming right before your eyes.
Never tried this before, not sure it will work,
but we're putting it to the test today for you.
So here we go Collins, let's grab some water bottles and bust some caps.
*music*
Oooh, it made like a, purple ink ring
and then the second one shot straight through it.
(counting) 1,2,3,4
*music continuing*
*laughing*
All we need to now is just
toss these in the freezer, for about 3 hours, and
just see the magic that happens.
Hey guys real quick intermission,
we filmed a video over on Collins' channel where we took gallium
and we made liquid metal fidget spinners.
So if you wanna see that, it was crazy, we lit them on fire,
we spun them, you can guess what happened next
but you're gonna have to go to his channel to check it out.
I got a link for you down in the description, go check it out.
Collins Key everybody.
He's got a channel you don't wanna miss.
Family friendly, good fun content.
As of this moment in time right now,
his channel is actually the number one, fastest growing
on youtube. It's absolutely amazing.
Go check him out, go subscribe, ring the bell
and while you're at it
if you haven't subscribed to this channel,
subscribe to this channel, and ring the bell. Okay?
So quick update guys,
we just checked the bottles
and they are starting to freeze.
So, we're gonna go grab some and bring them over here
and carefully take the tops off.
and pour them in this bin of crushed ice
and see who can actually draw
a frozen rainbow.
Almost like literally. *laughing*
Let's go get the bottles!
Let's do it!
Okay, we got the bottles out of the fridge,
here we go
we only got about 30 seconds
because they're warming back up, we have to be
very careful taking these tops off so we dont
accidentally freeze them .
You can see bottles are actually well below the freezing point of water right now.